[Musik]
immer mehr Deutsche greifen zum Alkohol
bei der Alltag für Sie immer härter wird
30 Prozent in Thüringen würden derzeit
die AFD wählen da steckt da dahinter das
besprechen wir hier heute bei viertel
nach acht mit diesen Gästen Journalist
Alexander Kistler wundert sich nicht
dass immer mehr Bürger den Respekt vor
unseren Politikern verlieren er
kritisiert die Infantilisierung und die
fehlende Kompetenz im Parlament von
wegen fehlende Kompetenz grünen
Politiker die italiane Check sagt die
Regierung kann Krise dank der heute
beschlossenen gaspreisbremse müsste
keiner von uns Angst vor einem lern
Geldbeutel haben meine Kollegin Zara
riffler blickt besorgt auf aktuelle
Umfragen wir jetzt in Thüringen das 30%
die AFD wählen würden daran dass er die
Regierung mitschuldig viele Bürger
fühlten sich abgehängt und nicht gehört
Autor und produktretter Stefan schrille
warnt die Industrie verkauft uns immer
mehr Schrott kommen aus dem Land ist die
Kaffeemaschine schon kaputt er verrät
uns heute wie wir wirklich gute Qualität
erkennen und teuer wirklich immer besser
ist es ist keine Überraschung während
der corona-krise ist der Alkoholkonsum
gestiegen besonders unter Berufstätigen
wer seine neue Studie zeigt die Mehrheit
sagt sie können so besser den
stressabbauen und auch die Kranken Tage
wegen Alkohol erreichen einen
Höchststand während Corona
trinkkarnation Deutschland Frust trinken
statt Genuss trinken Herr Kessler
abschalten mit einem Glas Rotwein jetzt
da schon gefährlich ich hoffe nicht weil
ich das sehr oft mache also ich komme
aus der Pfalz ich trinke gerne Weinen
das gehört für mich auch schon zum zum
Genuss dazu aber hier geht's ja glaube
ich um wirklich schweren Alkoholgenuss
Alkohol Missbrauch teilweise schon und
bewerbungswert ist natürlich schon dass
es vor allem die Berufstätigen in diesem
Fall trifft also nicht die jetzt unter
den Brücken liegen also
30 und 39 dann Anstieg um fast 89 %.
eigentlich unsere Leistungselite mit dem
Leben steht vielleicht Familie hat nicht
mehr den ersten Job sondern hat
karriereschrittmacht ähm ich hoffe nur
dass Sie hier bei uns nicht diese
sogenannte russ Krankheit ausbreitet
dann trinken sich vor allem die Männer
ja wirklich die Birne weg weil sie das
Leben dort nicht aushalten weil sie
perspektivlos sind und ich glaube das
deswegen muss man diese Zahlen so ernst
nehmen ich glaube wir hätten eine
Situation wie jetzt damit nicht fertig
wird dafür habe ich nämlich Verständnis
wenn es dazu einem dauerhaften gewöhnt
und dauerhaften Gewöhnungseffekt wird
ein Rausch wenn ich also sage ich kann
mein Leben nur noch im Rausch ertragen
dann bricht uns wirklich eine Schicht
Weg die eigentlich der Futter das
Fundament unserer Gesellschaft wäre
ein super Zitat ähm mir notiert das
kommt von ihrem Partei genossen Joschka
Fischer wahrscheinlich kennen sie es
auch wenn schon eine Weile her ist der
sagt der Bundestag ist eine unglaubliche
alkoholikerversammlung die teilweise
ganz ordinär nach Schnaps stinkt je
länger die Sitzung dauert desto
intensiver
ich glaube dass das in den Zeiten wo man
noch nicht so im Bild war also jetzt
kann man ja alles auch Phoenix Anschauen
von bis morgens bis abends noch mehr
gang und gäbe war dass dann getrunken
wurde auch in den Kneipen und man dann
in den Bundestag hineinmarschiert ist
und das einem keinen aufgefallen ist
wenn man dann sozusagen nicht mehr alle
Sinne beisammen hatte ich glaube heute
hoffe ich zumindest bei den allermeisten
Kollegen dass das verstanden wird dass
das sich nicht ziehen und ich will auch
sagen ich trinke auch Alkohol durchaus
auch manchmal vielleicht mehr als ich
sollte aber ich habe schon für mich ein
Einstellungswandel vollzogen also wir
haben halt so eine Kulturnation mit
Alkohol in Deutschland aufgebaut als ich
angefangen habe zu arbeiten weil bei der
Post und später auch mein Bayerischen
Rundfunk da gab es noch Bier Automaten
dann hat man das zweite Frühstück
gemacht mit dem Weißbier und heute ist
das undenkbar Gott sei Dank also es muss
die Leute schon aufklären und sagen es
ist nicht unbedingt cool du brauchst das
nicht wenn du es machen willst ist deine
eigene Verantwortung aber so dass es so
ein kulturellen Zwang gibt ich meine z.B
momentan weil ich das kriegt meine
Arbeit sonst nicht hin meine momentan
Zusammenkünfte wo man Alkohol die gibt
es ja hier im politischen Berlin jeden
Abend und der vielleicht nach der
Sendung mal doch mal ein Bier aber dann
ist auch gut ja also das muss also dass
man kann sehr viel trinken wenn man
möchte jederzeit und das ist verlockend
und viele sagen die Krankenkassen haben
jetzt echt Alarm geschlagen sie brauchen
das in den Stress abzubauen und den
Alltag zu vergessen machen sich da
Sorgen dass die Menschen so unter der
Krise leiden dass das im ernsthaften
dass die Leute nur noch negative
Nachrichten sehen und es war jetzt auch
ein schweres Jahr mal wieder wenn das
ist jetzt mit dem Krieg mit den
Energiepreisen mit der Inflation auf der
anderen Seite sind wir in Land in hohen
Wohlstand wir müssen auch wieder ein
bisschen mehr über die positiven Dinge
reden die ist auch in diesem Land gibt
sich von gestern Wolfgang Schäuble sehr
gut bei uns der auch mal gesagt hat also
er kennt jetzt 50 Jahre Bundestag und es
ist nicht die schlimmste Zeit die wir in
der Nationen erlebt haben wir hatten
auch schon andere Zeiten und ähm ja
natürlich den Menschen
Spaß noch mal schlimmer das hilft
natürlich denen die jetzt da vor dem
Winter arbeitet daran dass ich den
Leuten Mut mache und ich Angst mache und
das müssen vielleicht ein paar mehr
machen ja aus dem Handwerk Herr Schröder
da könnte es ja auch wenn es gerade
gehört das Weißbier oder das Bier das
schon mit dem Kasten eigentlich bereit
steht da gehörte das ja auch lange Zeit
dazu auf einer Baustelle oder in Betrieb
hat sich das auch so verändert wie im
Bundestag ist jetzt nicht ganz die Welt
wo ich rumlaufe aber die Handwerker die
ich kennengelernt habe passen nicht mehr
zu diesem Klischee also ich glaube das
ist das erfreuliche dass wir heute
sowohl unter Jugendlichen als auch unter
Erwachsenen auch eben gegen Entwicklung
halt feststellen
Alkoholmissbrauch ist immer ein Zeichen
für das was nicht richtig läuft und ich
glaube was wir dabei sehen müssen ist
Einsamkeit für viele Menschen sind
entweder mit sich selbst einsam
zum Beispiel aus der Krise oder sie sind
in Gruppe einsam das finde ich
eigentlich viel schlimmer nicht dass
Menschen eigentlich in diese Situation
hineinkommen dass sie dann miteinander
zusammen sind aber eigentlich sehen dass
einer gerade wegbricht ja also wenn man
in seiner unter seinen Kollegen sieht
dass einer nicht mehr nur eine Genuss
hat nicht den pfälzischen Weingenuss
sondern sich nur noch die Dröhnung gibt
und selbst Chefs nicht mehr sehen dass
alles komplett schief läuft das macht
mir doch schon Sorgen trotzdem muss ich
dieses mal sagen oder als ein Bild zu
bleiben etwa etwas Wein ins Wasser zu
gießen also man hat ja auch Umgang ab
und zu mit Parlamentarier und spricht ab
und zu auch mit denen es ist nicht so
dass der Bundestag zu alkoholfreien Zone
geworden die Belastung dort ist sehr
sehr hoch muss gut oder schlecht macht
ist erstmal Wurst ist Arbeitsbelastung
ist enorm hoch seine totaler Stress Job
und sehr viele davon trinken auch einige
zu viel einige normal einige gar nicht
aber der der Griff zum Alkohol ist also
jetzt im Bundestag alles andere als
verpönt das heißt ja wie viele Kilo bist
du schon im Bundestag also das geht dann
nicht die Jahre sondern die Kilo und
wenn man da mal reinkommt Gummibärchen
schlechtes Essen fettiges Essen
das kann man nur sagen muss man
vorwarnen und die Leute auch die neue
reinkommen die ist noch nicht so kennen
darauf aufmerksam machen ja Wolfgang
Kubicki der sagt auch man bekommt als
Politiker Zara ständig was angeboten
also gleich Insekt Empfang in der Früh
irgendwann gibt es ein Bier dann gibt es
auch noch ein Schnaps es geht die ganze
Zeit so weiter es gibt aber auch einfach
viele Dinge vielleicht die man sich fast
schon schön trinken muss das
Interessante ist ja auch an dieser
Studie dass die von quasi 2011 begann
also eigentlich eine Krise nacheinander
flüchtlingskrise Klimakrise corona-krise
Energiekrise der Krieg also jede Krise
ist eine Krise für uns Menschen zu viel
vor allem die die auch berufstätig sind
und sowieso schon unter gewissen Stress
leiden im Alltag und anscheinend ist es
gar nicht mehr zu stemmen in diesen
dauerkrisenmodus in dem wir uns befinden
und ich frag mich auch ehrlich gesagt ob
das die richtige Zeit ist auch demnächst
Cannabis zu legalisieren wenn wir solche
Studien haben indem immer mehr Menschen
gezielt aus der Realität verschwinden
wollen dass dieser immer krasserin
Realitäten der wir uns befinden ich
meine was für Bilder wir auch immer
sehen aus dem Ukraine kriegt
verschreckliche Bilder oder anders aus
sehr oft der Welt das ist ja nicht nur
so dass wir in Europa Musik haben und
Probleme haben und ich glaube diese
diese krasse kriseneinwirkung wirklich
führt dazu dass immer mehr Menschen sich
immer mehr in weg von der Realität
flüchten wollen zum Beispiel mit
Cannabis dass ihre Partei legalisieren
will ist das ein guter Zeitpunkt ich
glaube das ist richtig ist weil die
Menschen Cannabis sowieso konsumieren
das machen sie halt jetzt illegal hier
in Berlin oder in München wo ich
herkomme und es ist besser dieses
Substanzen zu kontrollieren vielleicht
auch zu besteuern Aufklärung zu machen
als diesen Schwarzmarkt zu haben der ja
dann auch die Cannabis mit anderen
Drogen vermischt also ich das ist immer
das Argument aber ich finde jetzt gerade
im Zusammenhang mit dieser Studie wo man
sieht es aus offenbar schon den Drang
gibt den Stress loszuwerden den Stress
irgendwie abzubauen dass man da nach
Mitteln und Wegen sucht das würde aber
auch bedeuten das könnte sich ja auch
auf Cannabiskonsum ganz anders auswirken
als erwartet wenn die Menschen genau so
derzeit mit ihren Alter das Problem ist
dass sie Leute haben die Drogenkonsum
nicht beherrschen können und manche in
seinem Lebensweg hat diese Zeiten
vielleicht auch schon so lebt und ich
glaube ich würde sogar sagen eine
Cannabis Droge dann die kann gut
konsumiert sein indem man sie halt milde
anwendet man kann sich das aussuchen man
muss ja auch nicht ein Schnaps trinken
sondern ein Bier oder ein alkoholfreies
Bier und so ist es dann auch ja damit
gemacht ich habe schon Cannabis geraucht
und ich würde mich auch wahrscheinlich
sogar etwas wegbewegen vom Alkohol wenn
die Cannabis Legalisierung kommt ja
alles klar
persönlich gefährlichere Droge
Gleichberechtigung die anstreben wollen
also wir haben ja gerade gesehen sie
haben berichtet vom Genuss des Weins und
deswegen werden sie ja nicht zum Wein
Alkoholiker wenn sie ihn genießen und
die Leute die jetzt in diesen Alkoholen
Missbrauch reinkommen haben wir ja
gerade gesehen dass nicht der Alkohol
die Ursache ist sondern der Stress im
Job die Überlast die Vereinsamung die
die völlige Überforderung nicht und wenn
man dann sagt ja dann sollten wir den
Alkohol verbieten sage ich ja damit
löste das Problem der Überforderung
nicht nicht geht die Leute nur nach
Hause zeigen sich ja was mache ich jetzt
nachher werden Sie vielleicht aggressiv
sehr oft du wirst irgendwo hin und dann
wenn du keinen Alkohol trinkst bist
schon blöd angeschaut ist ja selbst in
der Arbeitswelt manchmal so aber
ist einfach die Summe der verfügbaren
Rauschmittel erhöhen das würde ja
Geschehen Cannabis frei geben würde ich
bin der auch zwiegespalten als Liberaler
Mensch würde ich sagen das nicht machen
aber in der jetzigen Situation noch eine
Droge die auch Suchtpotenzial hat sagen
ja auch Ärzte freigegeben halte ich
jetzt doch schon für für sehr riskant
und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
schon alles letzte Hand abgewogen ist
der Schritt interessant was sie auch
gerade sagen das Problem quasi von der
anderen Seite einmal beleuchten eher an
die Ursachen zu gehen zu sagen woher
kommt der Stress woher kommt die
unzufrieden war halt woher kommt
vielleicht oft auch die
Aussichtslosigkeit das sehen wir jetzt
Zara in einer Umfrage aus Thüringen mit
erschreckenden Zahlen 30% würden die AFD
wählen du sagst die Regierung die trägt
da auch mit Schuld daran dein Thema ja
flüchtlingskrise corona-krise
Energiekrise wir leben wirklich in einen
Krisen ein Krisen Jahrzehnt nacheinander
und eigentlich wissen die Politiker vor
allem die bewegungspolitiker die Bürger
ernst nehmen und Sorgen auffangen und
genau das finde ich es ist in den
letzten Jahren nicht passiert seit 2015
bis heute besonders der corona-pandemie
hat man das gesehen als Menschen die
Skepsis hatten was ja erstmal legitim
ist sofort als Querdenker pauschal
verurteilt wurden und an den Rand
getränkt wurden bis hin zu ja nach in
die Hände von Extremisten geschubst
genau das ist so passiert man konnte das
Beobachten und jetzt gibt es neue
Wahlumfragen in Thüringen 30 Prozent
würden die AFD wählen das ist
erschreckend und auch in Sachsen die
neuesten Umfragen gehen auch darauf
hinaus nähern sich an die 30 Prozent
seit September und das die das ist die
Quittung davon und wir stecken jetzt
wieder in einer neuen migrationskrise
die teilweise auch gar nicht so benannt
wird und es trifft besonders wieder
Sachsen und Thüringen und das stärker
als 2015 wenn man sich die Zahlen
wirklich anschaut die Kapazitäten werden
knapp und man hat das Gefühl die
Politiker nehmen das nicht ernst von
Beginn an hat unsere
bundesinnenministerin gesagt wir hätten
keinen Kontrollverlust und äh eigentlich
dieses herunterspielen zieht sich bis
heute fort und das sehen wir dann in den
Wahlergebnisse wie wir es jetzt haben
erschreckenend
Zara also du sagst die Regierung hat
eine Mitschuld hört nicht richtig zu
kümmert sich nicht um die Sorgen der
Menschen ja man hat es ja gesehen solche
während der corona-pandemie das die
Menschen erstmal Skepsis hatten
besonders in den Ländern wie Thüringen
und Sachsen die ja historisch besonders
sensibel vorgeprägt sind das wird man ja
auch so sagen und da gab es halt sofort
die Zurufe von Menschen auf die Straße
gegangen sind ganz schnell ja das sind
ja alles Querdenker die sind alles
rechts und man hat diese Menschen damit
er erst recht an den Rand gedrückt und
ähnlich ist es eigentlich mit der
flüchtlingskrise gewesen sei vor 2015 in
der wir immer noch stecken und die auch
gerade steigt wenn man sich die Zahlen
anguckt und das z.B wenn Morde passiert
sind wie wir es jetzt auch in einer
Kirchberg sehen von einem Asylbewerber
mutmaßlich aus Eritrea das z.B
Priorisierung stattfinden also solche
Morde werden dann weniger von der
Regierung thematisiert als zum Beispiel
rechtsextremistische
Klamotten und diese Priorisierungen
diese Politik auch das Verschweigens und
tabuisieren von wichtigen Debatten die
in der Mitte stattfinden müssen führt
natürlich dazu auch das gewisse Leute
dann die AFD wählen weil die AFD diese
Themen die ja auch heiß sind diese
Themen muss man ja aufpassen das muss
man stark differenzieren für sich
vereinnahmen können und die Menschen ja
zu sich bringen ihre Partei regiert mit
verliert man zu sehr die Sorgen der
Menschen aus den Augen haben Sie eine
andere Erklärung für die Zeit
also es ist richtig dass man die
Probleme so benennen muss wie sie sind
und es ist auch richtig dass in der
Pandemie zu viel Ausgrenzung
stattgefunden hat gegenüber Menschen die
Maßnahmen kritisiert haben ich habe das
selber ein Stück weiter erlebt weil ich
die Maßnahmen gegenüber Kindern sehr
stark kritisiert haben weil dann schnell
im querdenkerlager wo ich absolut nicht
hingehöre
trotzdem muss man auch sehen historisch
gesehen Thüringen ist ein Land komme ich
dann doch mal in die Geschichte rein das
erste Land damals auf dem Weg zu macht
Ergreifung es gab Demokratie
Feindlichkeit Einstellungen auch schon
seit langer Zeit die gibt es dort und da
kann ich dann auch nicht sagen ich habe
alles Verständnis dann einfach auch
schlecht da muss man dann auch mit
Aufklärung und mit Gesprächen reingehen
und manchmal auch sagen Stopp halt die
Mehrheit sitzt dann doch anders was
jetzt den Fall in Iller Kirchberg angeht
aber unsere Staatssekretärin ist mehrere
Tage vor Ort die kennt sogar die Familie
persönlich also wir haben uns da schon
auch direkt gefunden hat gesagt ja dazu
sich nicht geäußert hat
quasi von Deutschland hat sich dazu
nicht geholfen ja gut die Frage ist
äußerte sich so jeden Mord macht
ja also das weiß ich nicht ja also das
ist ja ein sehr furchtbarer Mord gewesen
die hat ganz Deutschland bewegt also
wenn da nicht unser Bundeskanzler etwas
dazu sagen muss dann weiß ich auch nicht
aber ich kann nicht für ihn sprechen ich
kann nur sagen dass wir das schon
themaisiert haben das nicht nur also wir
haben das nicht nur bei den
Regierungsparteien wir haben das auch
lange gehabt bei der vorherigen
Regierungspartei CDU
ja eine Volkspartei die auch hätte die
Bürger auffangen müssen und sie hat
lange Themen z.B Integrationspolitik
Themen lieber der AFD überlassen weil
sie Angst hatten dann als Rechnung zu
gelten und deswegen wurde ganz lange
auch keine Debatte aus der politischen
Mitte geführt und das spürten das merken
natürlich auch die Bürger und das
Erspüren sie und gerade wenn jetzt so
derzeit der Asylbereich steigt an die
Grenzen und Ukraine schon seit Juni
übrigens ähm runter geht und ganz stark
der Asylbereich steigt dann kommt da
natürlich Fragen auf und das sieht
spiegelt sich in den Wahlergebnisse
nieder
bei uns die großen erfolgsparteien
befürchten sie dass es in Deutschland
einen Rechtsruck geben könnte so wie wir
es in anderen europäischen Ländern sehen
beispielsweise in Italien ja
mittelfristig kann man nichts
ausschließen kurzfristig sehe ich das
nicht das sind jetzt Umfragen vor einer
Landtagswahl die in anderthalb Jahren
sein wird glaube ich oder noch weiterhin
die bundesweit sieht auch nicht gut aus
15,5 Prozent hat Demokratie Parteien die
nicht verboten sind die darf man auch
wählen also man könnte jetzt auch über
27 % für die Linkspartei im in Thüringen
mache ich auch nicht da würde ich sagen
was noch mal die Wahlen ab aber wo sie
natürlich schon Punkt macht und das ist
glaube ich schon eine Verantwortung die
der jetzigen ampelregierung auch zukommt
und vor allem den Grünen und der SPD
dass sie abweichende Meinungen zu
schnell diffamiert einfach also wer sagt
ich will über die migrationskrise
sprechen der wird doch sehr schnell als
Ausländer Feind geframt die Familie
denunziert wer sagt wir haben einen
migrationskrise der wird als jemand die
Familie der sagen will wir müssen uns
abschotten vielleicht Grenzanlagen bauen
also wird wahnsinnig übertrieben die
vermehrungsoperation von Seiten der
Grünen von Seiten der SPD statt zu sagen
wir sind dafür heute vor Ort wir gehen
dahin wir schauen uns das an wir wollen
auch nicht dass dort Verbrechen
passieren warum sind die passiert dann
müssen wir aufklären und nicht zu sagen
da reden wir jetzt erstmal nicht drüber
Willkommenskultur ist uns vielleicht
wichtiger als innere Sicherheit der
Eindruck wird vermittelt Frau Fäßler war
bei diesem Anschlag auf ein ein
Flüchtlingsheim in Norddeutschland ist
ja nach als als brandstation glaube ich
herausgestellt hat ohne politisches
Motiv da war sie am nächsten Tag jetzt
hat sie dort ein relativ formal
formalhaften Tweet abgesetzt das war's
dann aber auch es war im Bundestag kaum
Thema bei den Regierungsparteien oder
nur im Nebensatz und das merken Leute
natürlich mit deshalb stehen wir sicher
vor einem kompletten Kippen des Systems
überhaupt nicht aber wenn immer mehr
Leute den Eindruck haben ich erlebe
diese Wirklichkeit auf den Straßen in
den Großstädten in meinem Dorf und da
sagt mir die Politik ach ist gar nicht
so schlimm wir finden neue
Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten und übrigens
bleiben wir angekommenes Land für alle
Menschen die zu uns kommen wollen dann
klafft einfach diese Lücke zwischen eine
Wahrnehmung der Realität vieler Bürger
und den Parolen der Regierenden und wenn
diese Lücke immer größer wird dann kann
irgendwann auch mal irgendwann auch mal
unsere demok Rutschen kommen wie plant
die Regierung diese Lücke zu schließen
sie haben selbst gesagt die Vermehrung
das große Wort sie gerade auch benutzt
haben haben sie erlebt in der
corona-krise als sie eine andere
Position eingenommen haben sogar von der
eigenen Partei muss man sich zum
Beispiel da entschuldigen entschuldige
das helfen wenn man sich entschuldigen
würde für die Fehler in der corona-krise
könnte das helfen diese Lücke ein
bisschen mehr zu schließen das Problem
mit der corona-krise ist dass er fast
keine Mitte mehr zu finden war in der
Diskussion und auch diejenigen die dann
gegen die Maßnahmen protestiert haben
viele von ihnen würde ich sagen haben
völlig überzogen in der Haltung das ist
dann nur noch um Freiheit gegen gar
nicht mehr am Schutz oder nur um Schutz
und nicht im Freiheit das ist ja völlig
unter komplex und ich glaube wir sind
alle traumatisiert als Gesellschaft und
es wäre in der Tat gut wenn auch
diejenigen die für sehr strenge
Maßnahmen waren und jetzt auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister einmal
zugegeben hat das Kita Schließungen und
da kann man auch ehrlich gesagt auch
sagen gleich Grundschule Schließung
keine Superstar Events waren und auch
falsch waren dass man immer sagt ich bin
der falsch gelegen und ich entschuldige
mich dafür anstatt zu sagen das ist
jetzt so und ich hätte es damals besser
wissen können oder nicht ja also das ist
eine Frage von Debatten Stil jetzt was
Killer gesagt hat ich würde die Realität
nicht ganz so beschreiben wie sie haben
wir jetzt wirklich in ganz Deutschland
gravierende Probleme im Bereich einer
migrationskrise nicht über wir haben
also wir haben natürlich
Herausforderungen wir müssen auch die
Themen ein bisschen trennen also wir
haben natürlich übrigens westbalkanroute
Thema da sind wir auch selber unterwegs
und sagen wir wollen dass da was
passiert das nicht mehr Leute noch zu
uns kommen ist auch ab Haltung der
Regierung auf der anderen Seite haben
wir das Thema Fachkräfte Zuwanderung das
ist völlig klar dass wir als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht ohne
Zuwanderung unser Wohlstand halten
können und die Wirtschaft ist damit uns
auf einer Seite also wir werden auch
Leute mehr brauchen wir brauchen auch
eine andere Willkommenskultur das Leute
sich auch willkommen es wandern viel zu
viel Leute ab ja aus Deutschland und es
gibt kriminelle aber es gibt auch
deutsche kriminelle Leute
gar nicht deutschland ist für Fachkräfte
ist attraktiv momentan für Leute die die
Sozialleistungen zu schätzen wissen weit
über und das ist schon ein Problem und
die Grünen und die FDP die Grünen und
die SPD vor allem haben finde ich keinen
scharfen Blick auf die Schattenseiten
der Migration die ist eben auch gibt
nicht nur aber die gibt's doch auch ich
kann doch nicht sagen jeder einzelne
Mensch der hier kommt ist eine
Bereicherung natürlich nicht er kann es
sein er muss aber nicht sein es kommt ja
nicht eine moralische besten Auslese zu
uns und das wird aber immer für diesen
scharfen Befürwortern dann ist Kultur so
vertreten dass man auf jeden Menschen
dankbar sein müssen das ist einfach
würde das nicht so sehen dass wir das so
sagen und auch nicht aber sie sehen das
anders ist wir sind ja auch ein
bundgemischtes Land also ich kenne in
meiner Verwandtschaft auch Menschen wo
ich sagen würde okay das würde mir die
Willkommenskultur vielleicht schwer
machen das ist aber nicht weil aus dem
Ausland kommt sondern es gibt halt
schwierige Menschen gibt nicht
schwierige Menschen ich will was
erzählen was mir heute passiert ist in
dem Zusammenhang was mir viel mehr
Sorgen dann macht ich saßen Kaffee
trinken und in so einem Geschäft und
dann kam ein alter Herr und wollte sich
dazu setzen und dann saß aber da ein
bisschen weiter weg ein Mensch weiß
unklar
und war so vor seinem Handy laut am
Reden hat sich mit jemand unterhalten ja
und dann sagte er während er wollte sich
da überlegt ob er sich zu mir setzt oder
wo er sich jetzt hinsetzt weil da war es
halt laut und dann sage ich wollte sich
zu mir setzen sagt dann nee auch nicht
und dann macht er folgenden Scherz sagt
er naja man weiß ja auch nicht ob da
nicht ein Messer in der Tasche hat
da sitzt ein Mensch in einem Café an dem
Tisch und redet vielleicht etwas laut
und das einzige was ihm als ältere
Mensch durch den Kopf geht ist man weiß
ja nicht ob dein Messer in der Tasche
hat in die fragte ihn nur wie kommen Sie
denn auf die Idee und das sagte ja in
Berlin hat sieben messermorde gegeben
meinte müssen mal rechnen wie viel
Verkehrstote ist gerade gegeben hat aber
es seine Wahrnehmung der Welt ist von
Medien geprägt um mich herumlaufen
Messer schleifende Ausländer oder sowas
da steht natürlich eine Überforderung
dieses Beispiel auch wenn sowas passiert
einer weiteren Sorge die glaube ich
viele gerade jetzt quält steigende
Gaspreise dann ab Januar oder Ölpreis
viele schon in den Geldbeutel und sagen
ich weiß es gar nicht wie wir hier durch
diesen Winter kommen wie real ist diese
Angst für Sie
für mich gar nicht ich lebe sehr sparsam
ich bin bei Energiewerke Schönau die
sind in Strom sehr günstig
für Kinder oder nein nicht ich habe zwei
Kinder bei meine Tochter da ist jetzt
ein bisschen wärmer gemacht die braucht
ein bisschen wärmer aber wenn ich dann
die alten Menschen sehe die überall sind
dann freue ich mich dass ich in einer
der günstigsten Wohngenossenschaften in
Berlin untergekommen bin die also bei
fünf Nacken knapp 6 € kalt liegt in
Berlin wo Studenten 400 € für 10
Quadratmeter zahlen müssen
geplante Obsoleszenz sehe ja und ältere
Leute den sozusagen dünne Rente durch
vorzeitigen Verschleiß aus der Tasche
gezogen wird die sich dann sagen ich
weiß ja gar nicht wo ich die nächsten
Fernseher hier kriegen soll und die
Wohnung wird auch immer kälter das sieht
man natürlich extreme Sorgen da kommen
wir gleich das ist gleich ihr großes
Thema und da hoffe ich mir auch ein paar
gute Tipps wie man da überhaupt vorgehen
kann und aufmerksam sein kann damit man
quasi nicht irgendein Schrott kauft
weihnachten steht ja auch vor der Tür
deswegen darf aber sie sagen wir kommen
gut durch diese Krise sie sagen all die
Menschen die sich fürchten jetzt in
ihren Geldbeutel schauen wirklich Sorge
haben sagen Sie können alle aufatmen ich
glaube schon dass wir jetzt eine
ziemliche Stabilität reinbringen für die
VerbraucherInnen also wir haben die
Strom und die gaspreisbremse heute
beschlossen
und wir haben auch entlastet dieses Jahr
95 Milliarden in drei Paketen das
insbesondere an die Haushalte geht die
geringe Einkommen haben oder gar keine
Einkommen also da ist was passiert das
Leute verunsichert sind und das ist
immer auch Härtefälle gibt das ist so
das muss man sich dann im Einzelfall
noch mal anschauen aber die Sorgen die
man haben konnte noch vor drei oder vier
Monaten die sind so nicht eingetroffen
und wenn es notwendig ist wenn wir auch
im kommenden Jahr weiter entlasten das
muss einfach gemacht werden ehrlich
gesagt ein Problem was wir haben wir
können das nicht machen machen was die
Amerikaner machen können nämlich einen
direkten Scheck mal an die Leute geben
der direktauszahlung zu machen weil wir
die Digitalisierung in Deutschland nicht
vorangetrieben haben deswegen mussten
wir jetzt ein sehr komplexes Gesetz mit
einer Strom- und gaspreisbremse machen
also so eine direkte Entlastung dann
auch gezielt an Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen das wäre das wäre noch ein
Traum
aber es klingt bei Ihnen zum
indest so klar sieht das ein bisschen
anders
wie wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam
anschauen wollen keine Sorge nicht von
ihnen oder sind sie auch auf tiktok das
hier bei der Bevölkerung eher noch ja
irgendwie zu misstrauen
[Musik]
ich komme bestimmt ich kann bestimmt
auch wieder auf die Beine
[Musik]
ich fühle mich jetzt fast so als müsste
ich jetzt auch so moderieren damit ich
sie auch sie liebe Zuschauer und
Zuschauer unterhalte aber jetzt mal
ernsthaft sie sprechen von der
Infantilisierung der Politik wenn man
sich so auf tiktok in den sozialen
Medien darstellt das ist für sie ein
Grund zu sagen irgendwie haben sie nicht
mehr alle naja auf Baustellen gibt es ja
oft das Schild elternhaften für ihre
Kinder wer haftet allerdings für
Erwachsene die sich für Kinder aufführen
oder schlimmer noch für Erwachsene die
andere Erwachsene wie Kinder behandeln
und damit willkommen auf dem Spielplatz
der Berliner Republik dort grassiert
nämlich neben anderen Viren auch das
Virus der Infantilisierung wir haben
Videos auf denen wir haben Beispiele
gesehen sogar selbst die Bundestags
Präsidentin Frau Bars sich also wie eine
Comicfigur zum Affen oder zu erfinden
macht wir haben Fotos Videos von der
jüngsten
Bundestagsabgeordneten Frau fester von
den Grünen die also Tanz werden eben
gesehen die grüne Landtags
Fraktionsvorsitzende Frau Schulze die
also mampfen lachend durch die
Fraktionsklausur Sitzung in Bayern führt
wir haben sogar ein Bundeskanzler der
spricht als wäre der
schiffschaukelbremser am Hamburger
Rummel wenn er von Bazooka spricht von
Wumms und Doppel Wumms und gleichzeitig
werden die Bürger von diesen kindlichen
Erwachsenen ihrerseits wie Kinder
behandelt also wir haben für 30
Milliarden wird uns erklärt wie wir
Energie sparen sollen der grüne
Ministerpräsident sagt nimm doch mal
Lappen vielleicht auch ein trockenen
duschen muss nicht sein also wir haben
leider Gottes beides Politiker die sich
in einer sehr ernsten Lage wie Kinder
verhalten mein dadurch auch Sympathie
Punkte zu bekommen aber ich würde sagen
wichtiger ist Kompetenz als diese
kindlichen Sympathiepunkte und wir haben
gleichzeitig eine Regierung die uns alle
wie Kinder behandeln will und mit diesen
beiden Form von Infantilisierung muss
Schluss sein ein Königreich ein
Königreich für etwas mehr Reife
einmal zusammen wir haben vorhin darüber
gesprochen früher gab es Trinker im
Parlament jetzt gibt es Tanzvideos dann
kann man eigentlich sagen naja was ist
daran so schlimm naja schlimm ist
zunächst mal ich will ja gar nichts
verbieten ich bin ja dafür dass die
Leute auf Freude haben bei ihrem Tun
dass sie lachen ich lache auch selber
die Frage ist doch immer in dem Fall ja
ich glaube mich keine Sorgen
ja aber die Frage ist doch immer mit wie
kriegt man in die Öffentlichkeit und wie
habe ich auch noch ein Rest von Ahnung
was das Hohe Haus so heißt das Hohe Haus
bedeutet und dann macht dort Frau Bart
irgendwie witzige Figuren und Frau
fester mit zwei anderen Jungen Gründen
Bundestagsabgeordneten tanzt irgendwie
herum es wird die Stimme verfremdet wir
müssen auch schauen das ist wirklich
voll dort wir vertreten die Abgeordneten
vertreten das Volk den souverän in dem
sie ihre Macht verdanken es sind sehr
ernste Zeiten wir müssen direkt uns
unterhalten aber doch nicht bitteschön
wie die Kindsköpfe was hat denn das für
eine Folge auch für die Gesellschaft
wenn man sagt an der Spitze es ist gut
ich kindisch zu geben also praktisch
nicht zu machen als du bist wir müssen
noch nach oben schauen wenn es versuchen
klug zu sein erwachsen
später auch gelassen aber doch nicht als
Kindsköpfe das sind leider Gottes auch
die Grünen nicht nur aber auch die
Grünen vorne mit dabei ich würde sagen
liebe Leute ein bisschen mehr erwachsen
sein im Umgang nach außen zeigen es ist
schön erwachsen zu sein an der steckt ja
auch der Kern noch ihrer Kritik drin ein
bisschen mehr Kompetenz absolut ja weil
natürlich in dem Moment in dem ich sehr
stark auf eine Emotionen emotionale
Ebene agiere auf eine sympathisch
wirkende lustige gigelende mampfende Art
wie das vor Schulz vielleicht gemacht
hat dann habe ich natürlich gar keinen
Raum in dem Moment im Kompetenz dieses
Kurs zu viel man sagt das ist lustig der
eine regt sich auf der andere klatscht
aber es werden ja gewissermaßen
energiere sehr wie immer für die
Kompetenz bräuchte abgeräumt wie kann
ich jemanden so wirklich ernst nehmen
wenn wir so jemand dessen Video ich im
Kopf habe nicht mehr rausbekomme der
wird mir jetzt erklären dass er in ganz
ganz ernsten Zeiten wir müssen alle den
Gürtel enger schneiden und danach sehe
ich dann wieder sich irgendwie lustig
macht über die würde die im zugefallen
ist wie gesagt gute Laune heiterkeit ist
nicht verboten aber bitte nicht so
infantil und das Stichwort
kompetenzialektiker wir haben viele auch
die überhaupt keine Berufserfahrung mehr
haben die nie im Job waren die
vielleicht auch noch gar nicht studiert
haben die sofort in die Politik
reinrutschen ist da manchmal zu wenig
Kompetenz und diesen Job auszuüben sehen
Sie es auch ja ich denke das ist schon
ein Anrecht ist zu sagen eine
Berufsausbildung ist was vorteilhaft ist
oder ein Studium wir haben natürlich
auch gerade bei den nicht akademischen
Berufen ein Defizit und jemand der ein
Handwerk ausübt als tierischen Beruf in
ihrem
Fraktion wir sind in ihrer Fraktion ich
glaube wir haben zumindest eine die
Handwerk macht aber es ist nicht eine
Handwerkerin haben wir glaube ich nicht
das ist wichtig ja
es gibt aber weniger ist ein Beispiel
dass er nicht nur über den Grünen so in
der Tat was jetzt das Verkaufen von
Politik angeht am Ende muss jeder seinen
Weg selber finden ich finde ein bisschen
Freude und von mir aus auch tanzen ist
okay man muss halt immer auch den
Zeitpunkt für diese Botschaften
überlegen ich selber machst seit einiger
Zeit anders oder vielleicht länger
auf Instagram wir sind jetzt auch eher
auf Facebook
ich habe euch momentan keine Zeit Fotos
zu machen ich schreibe jetzt einfach
blind Text rein weil ich finde dass der
Einfluss der sozialen Netzwerke
insgesamt negativ ist auf die Politik
also erst es ist zu viel Inszenierung
und es ist dann in der Tat auch ein
Verlust von Substanz und es werden dann
allerdings auch die Umgangsform in den
sozialen Netzwerken das werden sie auch
alle wissen sind so schlecht geworden in
den Jahren jetzt dass ich langsam nicht
mehr weiß wo befindet sich da eigentlich
dann die Diskurs Ebene ich habe früher
es ist nur noch jung aber es sollte man
hat doch aufgeschaut nach Berlin zum
Bundestag zum Reichstag das waren doch
also Legenden die dort arbeiten wir
haben unsere Sachen mit verhandelt und
jetzt werde ich tagtäglich und dass ich
suchen würde aber einfach mal ins Netz
gewinnt man zugeschüttet mit Videos von
Bundestagsabgeordneten die einfach
offenbar das gar nicht so ernst nehmen
genau
[Musik]
mit Würde zu tun und mit Würde des Amtes
zu tun und der Repräsentanz des Staates
und der Gesellschaft der wir ja
angehören ich will doch nicht vom
kindsköpfen vertreten werden das kann
mir auch keiner sagen 20-Jährige oder
22-Jährige jetzt ein Bundestag sind
würden für ihre Generation sprechen wenn
sie sich besonders infantil geben also
es gibt doch auch ernsthafte 22 und 23
jährigen warum gehen die so stark mit
dieser Message raus haben wir jetzt auch
Emily von uns die jüngste 22 Jahre alt
jetzt geht raus sie geht rein sagst du
Zara David jetzt junge Generation
abgeholt endlich frischer Wind ja also
ich bin ehrlich gesagt skeptisch ob
jetzt die jungen Generationen da ihre
die meisten Kompetenz mit reinbringen
sollen aber was interessantes werden am
Anfang die alkoholstudie jetzt haben wir
diese infantile
Politiker die eigentlich auch so tiktok
Politik machen und in dieser Social
Media Blase sich irgendwie auch von der
Realität wegfliegen wollen also sie tun
das
ich habe das Gefühl die Politiker tun
das auf eine andere Art und Weise sich
auch von der Realität wegflüchten zu
wollen das sieht man auch dann in der
Politik wenn das heißt wir haben keinen
Kontrollverlust an den Grenzen denn das
heißt wir haben keinen Stromproblem wenn
das heißt es gibt keine Insolvenz Welle
also diese
realitätslose Politik ist dann am Ende
auch dieses Produkt davon ja Schritte
wie sehen Sie das wir haben gerade
gehört wenig bei den Grünen keine
Handwerker beispielsweise wünschen Sie
sich mehr Pragmatiker mehr Menschen mit
Erfahrung mit Berufserfahrung in der
Politik also erstmal glaube ich das
Politik auch ein Handwerk ist das nicht
überall wo ein Hammer in die Hand
genommen wird das Handwerk ja also die
Zunge kann auch sowas wie ein Hammer
sein nicht und dann würde ich mir
wünschen sie haben ja klar also ein paar
Leute angesprochen nicht über von früher
kennen aber die haben wir ja heute auch
alle vielleicht sehen wir sie nur
einfach nicht mehr
im Kopf
gehen wir heute auch alle
würde ich jetzt gar nicht sagen
gar nicht so sehr deswegen sondern weil
wir viel wichtiger ist das für heute
noch eine andere Politik auf der Straße
haben nicht also wenn sowas wie Luise
Neugebauer auf die Straße geht oder oder
Gerät hat
also wir erleben einfach eine politische
Landschaft die viel breiter geworden ist
die sich auch unterschiedlich darstellt
ja was sie mit Würde des Amtes gerade
kommunizieren ist ja eher etwas was wir
aus den 50ern 16
Institution muss eine würde haben als
Demokratie sind Demokraten dann brauche
ich ja auch eine würde
also ja klar also ich glaube eine eine
lebendige Demokratie braucht auch
Lebendigkeit wenn die dann manchmal aus
dem Raum schlägt mag das alles sein aber
das würde ich jetzt nicht so als als
Engpass sehen sage ich mal viel
schlimmer finde ich tatsächlich das hast
du schon angesprochen wir kommen in eine
Zeit der Krisen nein wir sind schon
mitten in Zeiten von Krisen das heißt
wir brauchen vielleicht noch Heiterkeit
vielleicht brauchen wir bessere
Heiterkeit wir brauchen klare Sprache
aber wir brauchen keine klare Sprache
die mit Würde daherkommt sondern die mit
klarer Sprache leicht verständlicher
Sprache daher kommt die Leute mitnimmt
diese an Bord holt wenn das mit Lachen
passieren kann ist das Gute ich vermisse
mehr Humor in der Politik also ich
könnte mir also was wir von Joschka
Fischer oder soll ich noch gekannt haben
ja also nach dem Motto mal ein bisschen
humorvoll über die Stränge schlagen das
könnte uns glaube gut tun damit wir auch
mal Dampf ablassen können Humor ist er
gerade erwachsen das wäre man
Kritikpunkt dass wir nicht bei Humor
sind sondern bei
oberflächlicher ulknudelei und das ist
schon ein großer Unterschied ich bin
sehr viel Humor ich bin für Witz wie
gesagt für Heiterkeit Gelassenheit alles
da aber Weinsorten kann man aber auch
streiten nicht ich mache lieber den
trocknet Weine habe jetzt davon ich
hätte lieber nur Eiswein vielleicht ja
und was soll der trocknen
Würzburg
alles angucken kann man ja auch gar
nicht und
deswegen ist es ja immer so eine Frage
die man selber entscheidet ja dagegen
entschieden was geht Ihnen durch den
Kopf wir hatten ja jetzt gerade ein paar
Bilder gezeigt wenn man viele
Parteikolleginnen dabei denken sie dann
Gott ist das albern oder denken Sie so
neumodische Social Media Zeug ist
irgendwie nicht mein Ding oder denken
sie sollen die mal machen aber ich mache
sie haben sich ja bewusst auch dagegen
entschieden jetzt nicht ja ich habe mich
ich habe früher auch schon Gitarre
gespielt auf Social Media und mal
irgendwie im Wahlkampf was gemacht was
ich ein bisschen lustiger kann
authentisch ja jetzt machen wir doch mal
so ein tiktok Video bekommen in der Zeit
ich bin jetzt 9 Jahre Bundestag dass das
eine hohe Ernsthaftigkeit braucht in der
Kommunikation und ich lieber dann wenn
ich bei Facebook zum Beispiel schon eh
nur noch die älteren Leute kann man
sagen die jemand unterwegs was
reinschreiben was dann 5000 Leute lesen
dann bin ich da stolz drauf und wenn ich
ein Bild habe ist das schön ja aber das
ist ja nicht mein Ziel also ich möchte
ja mit dem Inhalt gesehen werden
nichtsdestotrotz verurteilt dich das
nicht also ich kann nachvollziehen wenn
andere das anders machen
ich persönlich schaue mir das ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht an weil ich
interessiere mich nicht für Instagram
groß ich bin da dort aber ich
kommuniziere rein in den Raum ich nehme
da nicht teilen ja ich verstehe halt
nicht ob das nur einmal noch zu sagen
warum eine
Bundestagspräsidentin wie Frau Bars das
ist glaube ich Nummer zwei oder drei im
Staat Nummer drei glaube ich was die
meint ihrem Amt ihrer Wahrnehmung ihrer
Partei sich selbst gut zu tun wenn Sie
sich hier zum Bugs Bunny macht bei einem
Instagram oder Tiki wieder
zurückgenommen danach gesagt so ein
Fehler aber was denkt man denn in dem
Moment wo man sagt das mache ich das ist
gut es ist Zeit in irgendeiner Weise auf
meinen Konto auf meinen Amt auf mich
persönlich an das verstehe ich glaube es
gibt ja so eine Diskussion dass man die
jungen Menschen erreichen kann nur mit
solchen Bildern das ist aber die Frage
ob das nicht eine zweite junge
Generation ist zu sagen die schauen sich
jetzt nur tiktok Videos an wo Leute
irgendwelche Kunststücke aufführen und
dessen das ist dann Politik aber
Ehrlichkeit halber ein Teil davon
erreichen natürlich auch über solche
Formate das ist auch egal die Kritik ist
ja auch wichtig wir brauchen Mut zum
Experiment Experiment nicht auf der
anderen Seite auch Kritik an der
misslungenen Experiment
auch die Wählerinnen und Wähler also
dass man mit gixie gaxi so würden sie
es wahrscheinlich überzeugen kann das
geht natürlich schon um Aufmerksamkeit
auch um Leute zu erreichen die Frage ist
wie weit wie weit gehe ich und wen
erreiche ich damit und möchte ich
bestimmte sogenannte Politik für eine
Zielgruppen erreichen
Politik also ich habe das
ist ja eigentlich nur Unterhaltung also
machen jetzt die Politiker Unterhaltung
also dafür haben wir sie glaube ich
nicht gewählt und gerade die großen
Parteien sollten sich eigentlich auf
ernste Themen konzentrieren wo wir
gerade auch gesagt haben was für
Krisenzeiten wir leben und ich finde das
auch ganz interessant die Grünen sind ja
eigentlich so die moralisch zu Partei in
den Bundestag was auch gar nicht so
schlecht ist bei vielen Themen gerade
wenn z.B um Iran geht aber wenn es dann
um tiktok geht ja also wo wir sagen das
ist eigentlich eine Überwachungstechnik
gewissermaßen von China dann ist es dann
plötzlich egal obwohl da gerade eine
Kurve Diktatur herrscht und Menschen in
einer Art von Konzentrationslagern sind
also da ist dann demoran auf einmal
nicht da und dann ist man dort kindisch
auf einer China app also
was man tatsächlich sehen muss weil sie
jetzt China sprechen weil wer sich so
auf Medien zeigt muss natürlich also
wenn ich mir dann überlege jetzt kommt
nur dieses Bild vielleicht in Chile
plötzlich auf dem Flimmerkasten guck mal
was in Deutschland los ist dritten Karte
dann merkt man schon so nee liebe Leute
dann wird schon schwierig ne also das
will man dann vielleicht auch nicht also
wir leben heute in einer in einer
Medienwelt wo es viele kaum noch
kontrollierbarer Kanäle gibt und da muss
man natürlich schon gucken mit welchem
Content völlig den kann Ausland über uns
würde ich jetzt unseren Beitrag einmal
quält die Welt verteilen auf den
deutschen kannst du gar nicht so
schlecht gehen für so eine Albernheiten
zeigerzeit haben offenbar haben die dort
noch furchtbar viel Spaß und gar nicht
allzu große Probleme das muss dieser
spezielle deutsche Humor sein sonst
keiner versteht ich denke das wird man
da denken ich würde es auch nicht jedes
einzelne zu hochherzen aber die
Grundtendenz ist einfach dass wir Gefahr
laufen ich habe darüber auch ein Buch
geschrieben dass wir Gefahr laufen nicht
das reife sondern das unreife auf
Protest zu stellen also der gute Mensch
ist der der möglichst ungefiltert seine
Emotionen rauslässt der kindisch ist der
ist nicht reflektiert der schnell
beleidigt ist stell Emotionen von
anderen provoziert aufnimmt und auch
wieder herstellt und das finde ich ist
haben wir als Gesellschaft eine Gefahr
wenn wir sagen das reife ist nur des
saturiert das wollen wir gar nicht das
ist irgendwie würde ich das ist erstaunt
genau und stattdessen einfach emotional
raushauen Emotionen hervorrufen das Kind
gewissermaßen auch immer Erwachsenen zum
Vorbild erklären als gesellschaftliches
Leitbild habe ich damit ein großes
Problem gar nicht so dass das so
wertgeschätzt wird man kann ja auch zur
Schulklassen gehen oder in soziale
Einrichtungen mache ich oft und dann die
Schülerinnen und Schüler die wollen auch
eine ruhige Sprache und die wollen es
nicht dass ich vor den Kunststück
aufführe also es ist vielleicht auch ein
falsches Bild einfach von jungen
Generation
entschuldigen
sie sprachen vorhin oder Sie sprechen
Kultur der würde
und dann würde ich aber sagen dazu
gehört aber auch eine würdevolle
Willkommenskultur und die haben sie
vorhin eher in Frage gestellt wir
sollten nicht jeden ins Land da
reinlassen aber menschlicher aber
Menschenwürde okay dann können Sie das
jetzt vielleicht habe ich verstanden
Kultur die angemessen
genau
nicht jeder Mensch der auf welchen
Pfaden auch immer nach Deutschland kommt
tut uns gut
drauf dass man nicht sagt jeder einzelne
ist automatisch weil aus einem
fremdgegangen
manchmal noch ein bisschen arbeiten dass
diese binden sie sich durchsetzt auch in
den Parteiprogramm und den reden würde
voll heißt natürlich jeden Menschen
seine unverlebarete zugestehen und die
auch wer zu schätzen es ist doch völlig
klar aber das heißt nicht die Augen
verschließen vor Problemen die uns auch
unter dem Überschrift Willkommenskultur
teilweise teilweise teilweise ist auch
noch mal teilweise behauptet werden
ganz kurze Pause jetzt hier bei viertel
nach acht die Grünen die Regierung
verspricht uns im Winter werden wir
nicht frieren das schauen wir uns
genauer an gleich nach einer kurzen
Pause hier bei Villach bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfördernden
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht holen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast totalitäre
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand aber das
ist alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und Umgebungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über dem Gerät
[Musik]
lange die Politik damit gerungen seit
heute ist sie durch die Gas und
strompreisbremse viele sollen entlastet
werden auch rückwirkend bereits warum
wir diesen Winter nicht frieren werden
das sagt uns jetzt Dieter
es gibt am Jahresende jetzt auch ein
paar gute Nachrichten das war wirklich
schwieriges Jahr der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine der leider
noch andauert hat dafür gesorgt dass die
Energiepreise explodiert sind es war
eine hohe Unsicherheit bei Ihnen als
VerbraucherInnen aber auch bei vielen
Unternehmen und jetzt haben wir heute
glaube ich was wichtiges geschafft
nämlich dass wir bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitstellen als Bund mit den
Ländern gemeinsam um eben diese hohen
Preise abzufedern auf der Strom auf der
gas-seite die zweite gute Nachricht ist
wir werden auch Versorgungssicherheit
hinkriegen diesen Winter das war nicht
selbstverständlich wir haben volle
gasspeichert jetzt langsam übrigens
beginnen sich zu lehren aber da wir auch
Energie einsparen was sehr wichtig ist
werden wir das diesen Winter schaffen
und wir werden dauerhaft wieder
günstigere Preise kriegen also das Thema
Inflation packen wir an und wir werden
das auch in den Griff kriegen so das
klingt
erstmal nach brechen
200 werden Schulden gemacht das sind
Schulden das sind Schulden die aber
notwendig sind weil ansonsten einfach
viele VerbraucherInnen jetzt in dieser
kurzfristigen Krise der sehr heftig ist
sozial mächtig unter die Räder geraten
werden und für manche ist es immer noch
schwierig das weiß ich auch aber ich
glaube wir haben jetzt viel getan mit
belastungspaketen insbesondere auch für
die unteren Einkommen und für die
Unternehmen ist es wichtig dass sie
wieder Planungssicherheit haben und das
haben sie mit dem heutigen Tag
nichtsdestotrotz ist die Krise nicht
vorbei wir werden auch weiter Energie
einsparen das hilft uns auch die Preise
weiter zu senken wir werden es Angebot
ausweiten bei Gas bei der erneuerbaren
Energien das heißt wir haben glaube ich
eine ganz gute Strategie jetzt für die
nächste Zeit aber entscheidend ist
natürlich dass wir uns ja auch raus ich
kaufen sondern raus finden indem wir die
Erneuerbaren Effizienz Einsparung die
neuen Technologien jetzt ganz konsequent
auf dem Markt bringen
sie sitzen schon auf heißen Kohlen dass
man das in den Zusammenhang überhaupt
noch sagen also geht die Politik hier
wieder mit zum Gießkannenprinzip vor ja
ganz Deutschland sitzt zurzeit auf
heißen Kohlen weil ohne Kohle wäre es
kalt zurzeit das ist mal ganz klar sagen
und die verteufelten fossilen
energiestoffe gegen die ein kleiner
Kreuzzug von Grünen und anderen
kalt momentan retten uns Gas und Kohle
muss man einfach sagen ist momentan so
ähm ich habe es nicht bis die letzte
Verästelungen die heutigen Gesetze
durchgelesen aber ich muss zur Kenntnis
nehmen das ist jemand der sich
eigentlich auskennen muss nämlich der
Beete i Präsident und deutscher
Industrie gesagt hat mit dieser Regelung
lassen lässt man uns die Unternehmen
nämlich im Regen stehen ich darf mal
wirklich zitieren das ist von heute die
Politik liegt mit ihrer Ignoranz
gegenüber den betrieblichen Realitäten
die Axt an die grundpfeile des Standorts
Deutschland das sagt
siegfriedrich-präsident der eingebunden
war in die Vorbereitung der
Energiekommission und dem heute wirklich
der Kragen geplatzt ist der gesagt das
ist zu bürokratisch Unternehmen wissen
nicht wann kriegen sie es sie wissen
nicht genau wie sie es beantragen es
gibt eine kappungs Grenze man muss
vorher schon nachweisen dass man 40
Prozent Umsatzeinbuße haben wird wie
soll das denn gehen also zu spät zu
wenig zu bürokratisch er ist völlig
verzweifelt und das zunächst mal eine
Stimme ich kann mir das jetzt nicht
alles eins zu eins zu eigen machen aber
diese Stimme muss man doch ernst nehmen
und es spricht für mich jetzt nicht für
gutes Regierungshandeln dass man nach
langem langen Verhandlungen mit einem
Ergebnis heute vor das Hohe Haus geht
doch die Mehrheit bekommt und dem der
daran beteiligt war wird der
BDI-Präsident sagt danach alles nur
Murks also warum ging man da nicht mehr
auf ihn ein warum hat man das nicht
vorher schon berücksichtigt ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass der Bild die
Präsident ist alles erfunden hat was ich
da zitiert habe können Sie gerne direkt
drauf eingehen ja ich war sogar gerade
beim BDI vor dieser Sendung also wird
eine Veranstaltung gemacht
das passt ganz gut aus genau zu diesem
Thema und kann Ihnen sagen dass die
Stimmung nicht so ist wie er sie
schildert natürlich sind Unternehmen
nicht zufrieden wenn sie groß sind dann
müssen sie jetzt ein sehr viel Geld
kriegen dann auch auf Boni und
Dividenden verzichten auf der
Vorstandsetage das findet nicht jeder
toll beeindruckt aber ich finde das ist
auch ein Preis jemand zahlen kann wenn
man 50 100 oder mehr Millionen Euro dann
Zuschuss kriegt nächstes Jahr ansonsten
kann ich sagen wir haben ein Problem was
noch nicht endgültig gelöst ist das ist
diese Obergrenze also es gibt halt ein
paar Konzerne chemische Industrie
insbesondere die würden auch gerne halbe
Milliarde Euro in Anspruch nehmen von
den Zuschüssen wenn sie nicht eh schon
wieder auf dem Markt einkaufen können
können nämlich manche schon Strompreise
sind gesunken und das ist ein Problem
was wir noch mit der europäischen Ebene
endgültig klären müssen aber sie sehen
keinen Stromproblem keine ganz Problem
kein Ölproblem ab Januar es hängt
wirklich davon ab dass wir jetzt weiter
Energie einsparen und man muss auch
sagen jetzt haben wir sehr kalte Tage
gerade da verlieren wir an einem Tag bis
zu 1% vom Gast speichern das muss man
ganz anders sagen
ziemlich viel also ich glaube viele
haben diese 19 Grad Regel hier bei uns
auch zu Hause geht jetzt in den außen
wäre es nicht macht zahlt dann halt mehr
aber ich glaube es wäre wünschenswert
und wir wissen jetzt einfach von dem
Planungen her wir haben einen LG
Terminal das jetzt am Sonntag geöffnet
in rekordseite öffnet das wünsche ich
mir übrigens einfach für die
Windkraftausbau und wir haben jetzt
Einsparung und 2025% in Industrie
gesehen wenn wir das beibehalten werden
wir nach den Zahlen die wir kennen durch
den Winter kommen und dann müssen wir
natürlich nächstes Jahr die Gasspeicher
wieder füllen müssen die insolvenzwellen
zeichnen sich bisher nicht in der Form
ab ehrlich gesagt sehen wir die nicht in
dieser Form momentan es gibt sicherlich
einzelne Betriebe die zu kämpfen haben
aber im Wesentlichen sehen wir momentan
sogar konjunkturell wieder leichte
Aufschwung Tendenzen Konsum Konsumklima
ist gut also wenn es gut läuft kommen
wir nicht mal in der technischen
Rezession in den nächsten Jahren
keine Glaskugel aber man kann ja schon
man kann zumindest die These vertreten
und soll ich jetzt mal machen dass man
in diesem harten Winter sieht dass der
Traum der Energiewende zum Albtraum der
die Industrialisierung führen kann wir
haben jetzt unvorhergesehene Faktoren
das ist doch völlig klar Ukraine kriegt
etc streitet niemand aber wer sagt uns
dass das nicht auch in 4 5 6 8 Jahren
noch mal kommt sie haben jetzt die die
Windräder angesprochen deren Ausbau
vorangetrieben werden soll wir hatten
die letzten Wochen
konnte man den offiziellen Daten enorm
entnehmen viele viele Stunden tagsüber
dunkelflaut da hat sich fast kein
einziges Windrad gedreht diese drei
Atomkraftwerke die wir jetzt momentan
noch haben haben dürfen haben mehr
Energie gemacht als alle 30.000
Windkraftanlagen also ich glaube wenn
wir uns jetzt wirklich mit diesen
Erfahrungen spornstreichs weiterhin in
diese Energiewende hinein begeben 20:45
Uhr komplett CO2 neutral zu wirtschaften
fürchte ich dass wir das Risiko haben
einer der Industrialisierung entgegen zu
laufen und sie haben selbst gesagt das
Angebot muss erweitert werden deshalb
finde ich man müsste auch wirklich reden
über Atomkraftwerke vielleicht sogar
über Fracking und dieser eingängige Weg
der schreibt mir wirklich nicht mehr an
aktiv los zu sein hin zu 100%
erneuerbaren Energien ich glaube dieser
Winter zeigt es vielleicht zeigt es der
nächste Winter sogar noch schlimmer mehr
Stromsparen also sagen Sie uns wie es
geht haben sie ein paar Tricks auf Lager
was man machen sollte und was auf keinen
Fall das Stecker beim Fernseher raus und
rein der Tee Kocher oder irgendetwas
Menschen sind das einfachste ist
wirklich sich seine haltbare Leiste
anzuschaffen also bei mir zu Hause
Waschmaschine kann ich an Stecker
abschalten damit die nicht bloßweise
rumsteht Strom verbraucht genauso
Fernseher also überall einfach
abschalten abschalten abschalten
einfach die Dinge und sich dran gewöhnen
zack ausmachen nicht bei mir gibt's
nichts auf Standby oder so also kann man
einfach eine ganze Menge machen die
einfachste Sache ist wirklich auch daran
zu denken ich brauche eigentlich nur in
dem Raum wo ich bin Licht
und wie viel Leute müssen unbedingt
immer ihre ganz ganze Häuser erleuchten
Waschlappen
es gibt ja tolle Sache die würden
noch massieren
was eigentlich nicht da ist ich frage
mich dann viel mehr warum eigentlich für
ganz viele Dinge stromgeräte gekauft
werden die vielleicht gar nicht
gebraucht werden
das Geräte kaufen die lange halten
Problem ist nur wir halten oft gar nicht
mehr so lange und da sind wir schon
mittendrin genau
ja wir haben jetzt Weihnachten vor uns
und alle laufen in die Regale rein und
was macht der Handel erstellt uns
Produkte rein von den wir nicht mehr
wissen wie lange die eigentlich halten
werden da muss man ja schon bald Angst
haben dass die meisten
Weihnachtsgeschenke nächstes Jahr schon
wieder kaputt sind und wie kommt es die
meisten Produkte werden eben heute so
gebaut dass sie maximal die
Gewährleistungszeit überstehen also zwei
Jahre viele gehen schon vorher kaputt
für einen vielen gibt es schon vorher
gar keine Ersatzteile mehr muss im Regal
und da wünsche ich mir eigentlich dann
doch eher dass der Handel endlich mal
dafür sorgt dass wir wieder sorglos
einkaufen gehen können heute muss man ja
sozusagen eine Detektei Gründen bevor
man den Weihnachtsgeschäft rein möchte
nicht um eben zu finden ja bitte welche
Produkte sind das die ich hier noch
kaufen kann wo nachher meine Kinder zu
mir kommen und sagen was hast du mir
dafür murgsgeschenk nee schon wieder
kaputt gegangen ich habe meine Tochter
die wollte unbedingt haben Schuhe aus
dem Billigladen in Berlin überhaupt ja
nach drei ich glaube drei Wochen kann
sie schon wieder eine Sache ja hat nicht
gehalten die geht dann nie wieder
einkaufen nicht also wir sollten einfach
beim Einkaufen darauf achten Haltbarkeit
wie macht man das ich habe heute gelesen
40% der Menschen sind mittlerweile
einverstanden sich etwas Gebrauchtes zu
Weihnachten schenken zu lassen das finde
ich eigentlich eine ganz tolle Sache es
gibt heute neuwertige Dinge die man sich
online kaufen kann auf aufgebraucht
Börsen ebay etc was ist da alles gibt
das heißt wir haben für uns selbst die
Möglichkeit vielleicht einfach mal neu
nachzudenken das schönste wäre finde ich
angesichts der Einsamkeit die sich an
vielen Orten breit macht die
gesprächsbedürfnisse die da sind die
Krisen den Druck der auf uns lastet der
da ist das wichtigste ist wir schenken
einander mal wieder Zeit reden über die
Dinge unter Handel sollte endlich dafür
sorgen dass er seine Regale aufräumt
denn geplant hat obsolut sens hat dort
nichts zu suchen das klingt wenn ich das
höre fast für mich wie nach Betrug ich
gehe jetzt völlig naiv im Laden und
denke das was ich kaufe das wird ja wohl
halten früher hatten Auto eine Million
Kilometer geschafft gibt's heute einfach
nicht mehr würden sie selbst von Betrug
sprechen es gibt betrug es gibt was sie
viel schlimmer finde ist das Blödheit ja
ich bin selber diplombe Betriebswirt
kommen aus dem Konzernbereich ich bin
selber gewesen etc man kann ungefähr 80%
der Konsumgüter ohne Mehrkosten mit
dreifacher Haltbarkeit herstellen das
heißt doch vom Marketing her tolle Sache
ich sage dem einen mach mal haltbarer da
können wir ja noch mal ein bisschen was
draufschlagen bitte nicht gierig sein
das heißt ich könnte in der Summe
nachher mehr Grenzertrag nehmen wir das
machen obwohl wir kaum Grenzkosten haben
nicht wenig reinstecken ein bisschen
raufschlagen die Dinge halten länger wir
haben Ressourcen Probleme heute in den
Unternehmen das sehen wir ja durch
Corona schon immer weniger Produkte
waren Stoffe kommt zu uns nach Europa
wenn die Dinge länger halten haben weil
weniger Sorgen weil es einfach länger da
ist das ist wirtschaftlich sinnvoll das
ist für ein Konsumenten das ist für die
Umweltschutz das ist für alles mögliche
sind voll nicht und dann muss man
wirklich sagen geplante ob soll es sein
also das mutwillige Kurzlebigkeit
einbauen einfach blöd anscheinenden sie
so zufrieden mit der Politik jetzt aber
muss man sagen da kommt schon ganz
schöne Kritik auch hoch neben Ihnen
sitzt jemand aus der Politik sie
begleiten dieses Thema sehr glaube ich
20 Jahren das ist
ich mache heute alle Eltern hier in
dieser Sendung
danke als vereinbar wirksam als wäre es
20 Jahre tätig gewesen aber viel
wichtiger ist ja in Frankreich gibt es
schon Gesetze in Deutschland ist
geplante Obsoleszenz leider immer noch
erlaubt den passt ganz Europa ist
geplante Obsoleszenz immer noch erlaubt
in Italien ist Apple schon verurteilt
worden wegen geplanter 15 also hier muss
was passieren wir haben vor der Sendung
gesprochen und ich kann das nicht sagen
weil ich in dem Bereich nicht tätig bin
ich bin ja im Wirtschaft und ich im
Umweltbereich wo das dann angesiedelt
ist ich weiß aber dass es sowas wie ein
Recht auf Reparatur schon in Schweden
gibt dass die Europäische Union auch
entsprechende Pläne verfasst hat also es
gibt eine Diskussionsprozess und ich
kann das nicht vorstellen dass wir das
nicht wollen aber ich kann nicht sagen
wo der Stand ist könnten sie sich ja mal
seltenen sicherlich haben Sie ja auch
Interesse daran das Gerät lange halten
dass man die ganze Zeit neue sie haben
schon Kärtchen ausgeschaut
heute morgen aufgewacht und mein zwei
Jahre altes Handy ist nicht mehr
angesprungen und dann bin ich zu einer
Reparatur Laden gefragt und jetzt wieder
aufgemacht ist gut dass die reparieren
gibt aber das ein Handy nach zwei Jahren
dann einfach nicht mehr funktioniert ist
halt auch wieder so ein Problem Berlin
treffen sich Menschen machen gemeinsam
Dinge heile in Repa Cafés 42 Repa Café
1600 ungefähr in Deutschland schon eine
ganz Europa hat sich das ausgebreitet ja
ich habe vor kurzem gesehen wie ein
Junge sein Vater auf dem Kopf gehauen
hat weil er gehört hat Mensch mir löten
beibringen können da kann ich mal wieder
was also Leute Kolben zu Weihnachten
schenken top Geschenke ja
heutigen Zeit habe
aber ich gebe ihn total recht secondhand
da bin ich mit dabei und bei Produkten
draufschauen sind sie verklebt stehen
lassen
ja verklebte Produkte den Verkäufer
fragen wie mache ich das eigentlich auf
da gibt es Stabmixer die sind komplett
verklebt wenn der kaputt geht ist ein
Einwegprodukte da geben Sie also 40 €
von Stabmixer aussehen könnte am Schluss
noch 2 Jahren wegschmeißen weil der ist
nicht mehr reparierbar ist auch gruselig
das ist wirklich unser anschauen einfach
mal hingucken nach dem Motto die Gelenke
der kommt also alles was sie irgendwie
nur bewegen könnte dann Nutzungszeit
anschauen wenn das klappt nicht aussieht
stehen lassen aber viel wichtiger mal
den Chef her rufen und sagen Sie mal rum
stellen Sie morgens ins Regal ich gehe
bei ihm bald nicht mehr einkaufen also
Augen
es war eine schwieriges Jahr und wir
wollen uns ganz herzlich bedanken das
war ein Jahr der Krisen es waren ja der
schöne Momente wir wünschen Ihnen hier
von unserem gesamten viertel nach acht
Team ganz frohe Weihnachten genießen Sie
diese Feiertage wir machen eine ganz
kurze Pause und wir sehen uns dann
wieder am 10 Januar ganz herzlichen Dank
auch noch mal an diese Runde an meine
Gäste und ihnen danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]